earlier in the press conference Andy
Reid said he has no thoughts on how much
longer he will coach there's no reason
to stop now he's 61 both Pete Carroll
and Bill Belichick deep into their 60s
and if not already 70 close to it and
you've got Patrick mahomes and the
stories and they're already legend Bret
Veatch who wasn't the GM at the time but
maybe helped earn his stripes by being
so vigilant and so insistent that
mahomes is great best guy he's ever seen
and Andy Reid finally gives in and looks
at the tape says isn't best guy I've
ever seen and the rest is history traded
up from 27 to 10 to get him cut in line
in front of Sean Payton in the Saints
who talked last week to us about what a
tough decision it would have been
between Marshall autumn or Patrick
mahomes that both were on the board at
11 didn't have to make that decision
Lattimore was there because my homes
wasn't and now my homes is in Kansas
City for the rest of his career Chris
yeah that's right I mean that's a you
know organizational like changing move
to trade up for a Patrick mahomes right
there generational talent and an Andy
Reid yeah because he's seen guys like
Brett Favre in person could recognize
that talent that's why you know when he
was coming out in the draft Mike and you
can go back and watch my videos I was
going this is Aaron Rodgers just brett
farr if he's doing crap I've never seen
anybody do before just throwing it all
over the place and he's changed the DNA
structure of that organization forever
and you know the things that I find
interesting they're like his ability to
come back to the sidelines and like you
know be able to tell everything that he
saw on the field yet the games like you
know we always hear this the games in
slow motion for him he's just so
comfortable he's so talented he's always
loose he sees everything it's like you
know I it's almost I hear him ahead that
some of these answers sometimes the way
he explains it and some reminds me of
like Peyton Manning used to be after a
game he could explain every detail Kubek
well that guy's right I was over here
and the left I was over here and he had
his index finger on his you know on his
thigh pad and I think that's what amazes
Andy Reid not only the talent but the
guy has the brain and the wherewithal to
just digest it all and never be
flabbergasted and that's where he's
amazing and you know Reid also said they
have more that they will be adding to
the offense one of the stories that was
yesterday at NFL Network and NFL calm
behind-the-back pass that had from homes
has been lobbying read to use in a game
apparently he can throw it twenty yards
accurately behind the back I mean that's
amazing but I don't doubt it I you know
I went through the first five or six
games I ever saw this kid play go and
that's lucky that's lucky that's lucky
I'm still saying that's lucky because
he's that great it doesn't matter
anymore it's not luck he's just that
freaking amazing he's unbelievable it
was awesome it was a great show doing it
with you today Mike you don't look that
tired safe travels back okay I feel good
because I was right congratulations to
the Chiefs we'll do it again on Tuesday
everybody enjoy your Monday see you
tomorrow see ya
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports